miss Turner
Oh
when the star wars the force awakens
trailer came out last month we thought
we were pretty much done seeing new
footage but we were wrong the
international trailer hit the web this
morning and oh my god it's a ton of new
footage I'm not gonna lie it was a
little too revealing for me I kind of
just want to see the movie at this point
but I watched it so now let's break down
the six things we learned my family
there are endless theories about this
but Ray is definitely related to someone
she's a self-described loner and
scavenger but hey she said she has a
family and speaking of ray this is the
moment I wasn't ready for
in a clear holy moment kylo Ren pulls
his lightsaber out on ray and I would
have lost my mind in theaters on the
flip side we now know that Chewbacca is
more badass than we ever thought we saw
this explosion before but turns out
chewies causing it we can effectively
crown bb-8 as the cutest droid on jakku
and we finally get to see our long-lost
c-3po complete with a red arm but still
no Luke Skywalker then none for Gretchen
wieners five
you